welcome back your man notice it's pride
month it's pretty hard to ignore it the
rainbow flag has been hosted over
London's Regional Street in place of
Union Jack and Drake from the White
House balcony in place of a
Star-Spangled Banner which has sparked
quite a backlash in the states have we
gone rainbow crazy or is pride month
more important than patriotism or debate
this I'm joined by Fox news commentator
tell me later in and then the studio the
comedian James but right Tommy off you
go you're enraged by this why
well listen I wouldn't say I am enraged
by it but I am irritated and a lot of
American conservatives agree with me now
listen pride month is not a new thing
they've been celebrating pride month for
many many years and most American
conservatives had no issue with it until
it became
forceful until it became the need for
acknowledgment the need for for
celebration the need for Force
validation that's when you lost people
and then
we took LGB and then we added
lgbtqia plus plus and then we included
men who dress up like women and mock
women like influencer Dylan Mulvaney and
that a lot of American conservatives
just said listen we've had enough it's
okay if you're proud of your sexuality
but why do I have to be proud of your
sexuality that's where you lost a lot of
folks and we're starting to fight but
firstly I'll say delegate trans woman
Dylan is a woman so you got that wrong
and secondly well Dylan was Dylan was a
gay man until last year I Dylan was a
gay mantle last year they've
transitioned they're a woman I think
that we lost people right at the
beginning when gay people were dying in
the streets because no one was looking
out for us so actually what we're doing
right now is just I wouldn't even use
the word celebrating I think pride is a
protest has it been is it a bit too much
in other words do you want to what does
that mean what is too much in other
words I think with every campaign
bringing people with you is really
important right the moment it looks like
it's just over the top like it's
everywhere you go it's Pride Prime do we
need to be that well are you blaming gay
people for that I mean oh I thought the
company honestly I don't care what
sexuality anybody is I don't think most
people do anymore right so what is the
problem then why are you so triggered
here's a buy a flower
attention I'm not triggered by rainbow
flag I'm triggered by the fact that
everywhere I go for a gallon a month
everything has to be a rainbow play
until I'm triggered that everywhere I go
for the entire year everything has to be
straight where is it why is straight
where's my Straight flag why am I
constantly straight Flags straight
people holding hands in a straight flag
why is Mickey Mouse tell me one straight
flag okay anywhere in the world why are
straight people
identity where's the straight flag
everywhere where's my Straight flag it's
everywhere it's never been a straight
flight you're a straight flag
let me bring Tommy back because this
made me laugh Demi Lovato has revealed
she got tired of using they them
pronouns due to constantly having to
educate people about it she said it was
exhausting what I know the feeling uh
Demi she's exhausting isn't she Tommy
it's all exhausting listen nobody cares
what you choose to be it's just this
everybody has to keep up with what you
feel like today or tomorrow everybody
has to change the way that they address
you and if somebody heaven forbid makes
a mistake then all of a sudden they're a
transphobe and they're akin to a
domestic terrorist is absolutely
ludicrous that's absolutely not true
that's right and by the way how many
letters are there now no I let you talk
exactly it lets you talk you finish told
me I finished you're right finish your
point
yeah and there's another part of this
whole pride thing listen if it was just
rainbows and love is love there's no
problem with that if you look at a nine
or ten of these Pride events it's grown
men and grown women wearing bondage gear
smacking each other often children are
involved to watch this special I mean my
goodness if you want equality
they Sam is that they pronoun sorry
please Sam used to be a he too right we
can't keep up with any of them Demi
Lovato used to be there
gay rights to equality absolutely 100
always happy answer one question how
many letters are there now how many are
there it's a flag that represents how
many of you don't even know how many are
there I don't need exactly my I need to
know because it's not about there are so
many letters now we can't keep up with
it's not about that it's about
inclusions
and now we found out according to uh to
the John Hopkins Medical University in
Baltimore that apparently lesbians are
now no men no man who have relationships
with no men no men
is there to represent lgbtq plus people
and minorities and like all sorts of
movement like black lives matter the
reason it's so loud and to qualify you
exhausting okay because we need to all
right but I do want to come back next
time I speak to you to the straight flag
that you say exists which I've never
seen right because I want my own
straight flag sure Tommy great to see
you uh great to see you may I wish you
happy pride month
whoa whoa